of course they remember how to do it
it's what everyone in this industry
loves live music
the bars are prepped and there's a
festival
to fire up no masks and no distancing
for the 5 000 ticket holders
at sefton park in liverpool and the
indie band blossoms
headlining this latest test event that
doing it in a slow manner
is based you don't want to go back and
it happens and something happens and we
have to go back do you mean 10 steps
i'd prefer to take this a little bit
slowly yeah we've got waited this long
now i think if people
if they said you know i think at one
point we would i'd have been willing to
wait till next year
if if they could have guaranteed we'd be
back so you know
we're not in any rush to just you know
open it too fast i think
it's better to do it like joe said in
the way we're doing it now
[Music]
this weekend in liverpool has been a
real crowd pleaser
two nights of clubbing by the docks and
now the festival in the park
at the heart of this is how much does
the government want to please the whole
crowd across the country
by easing lockdown even faster liverpool
has had a taste of freedom this weekend
and unsurprisingly people have loved it
four of these kids thank you these are
the dive scallops from west dorset
at this farmers market in west london
jamie was just pleased to be selling his
scallops from dorset again
it's been five long months without these
customers
it means so much because we've got our
own boat down in dorset you know we've
got all those fixed overheads which we
haven't been able to
to actually utilize and and we've been
ready to go et cetera et cetera but
nowhere
to actually sell our fish so to have an
outlet back
in london back on stream is is great for
us
it's really very optimistic and i feel
very good about it but at the same time
i feel the way we
shop and the way we go about our daily
things have to change a bit and we have
to be still careful
this has changed for a very long time to
come now and i think we will all be
conscious of sort of
how things spread and you know where
maybe we weren't before
however busy it gets everyone is being
reminded
to keep at it things are good things are
really good
and we mustn't lose all of that ground
that's been gained we have to remember
there's still something like two and a
half thousand people in the uk
uh with covet 19 and any of those
could form the nucleus for a further
explosion in cases
in liverpool at the center of the
experiment they're just ready for
another big night out
science lessons don't come much better